[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now so it may
only be monday but we are ready to
cheers to next weekend old homestead at
caesars palace is hosting a wine pairing
brunch on saturday november 6th and we
are getting a little preview of the menu
today joining us is old homestead
executive chef bart younger bart thank
you so much for being here thank you for
having us on you've been cooking up a
storm since you got in here what are you
making uh this is going to be on our
sunday brunch this weekend our saturday
brunch
this is our lobster benedict served with
a potato pancake
some sauteed spinach and an old bay
hondas wow well let's talk about the
event because this isn't just a simple
basic brunch here you guys are taking it
to the next level let's talk a little
bit about the pairings and what people
can expect if they come out to eat so
we're gonna have a five course pairing
this uh saturday it's gonna be with e
and j gallo wines
the lobster benedict will be being
paired with our j vineyards pinot noir
from russian river is this what i'm
holding right here
[Laughter]
and so our dish today is going to be
starting off with a potato pancake that
we made earlier okay
we've got some of our sauteed spinach
it's all smelling so good and i know
you're going to get to this lobster tail
in a minute but this is huge and this is
what the portion will be like if people
come in and order it no we're doing five
courses so you get a part of this
otherwise
way too full one course and you'd be
done what's the next step here so uh
it's a little bit we get a couple ounces
here we've got a couple ounces of our
tail going on our set here
and then it is finished with
a poached egg
oh it's looking good see an egg for
breakfast goes perfectly with wine
things are good on everything any time
yes absolutely
and then we're finishing it with a
little bit of old bay hollandaise
looks delicious sprinkle of chives and a
little bit of old bay
and then all you need is your glass of
wine and you're ready to go glass of
wine we're gonna throw a little lobster
claw in there and uh
you're having a wonderful saturday
brunch at caesar's palace yeah so people
want to come out do they buy the tickets
in advance or how does it work uh you
can actually get tickets on open table
and right now they're running at 140
okay is there a start time or can you
come throughout the day 11 30 is our
start time we'll be starting off with a
couple past appetizers and then moving
into the five course wow so it's a
really good deal yeah and if you're
coming to this brunch i say don't eat
dinner the night before because like you
are going to be hungry and then super
full after all of this exactly yes well
thank you so much chef this smells
delicious if you guys want to go in just
caesar's palace 11 30 get your tickets
online and hey you can never say no to
wine right yeah we gotta cheers